Let us now go back to example of the baseball pitcher who has to
decide on a action to take in a particular circumstance. So
we can think of this pitcher as mapping a percept history into an action.
Now imagine that this pitcher is embodying a production system. We are back
to a very specific situation, and you can certainly read it again. Recall that
David had given the answer, the pitcher will intentionally walk the batter. So
we want to make the theory of how might the pitcher or internal and
AI agent come to this decision. Recall the very specific situation that
the pitcher is facing. And recall also that David had come up with this answer.
So, here is a set of percepts, and here is an action. And the question is,
how these percepts get mapped into this action? We are going to
add one build a theory of how the human pitcher might be making these decisions,
as well as a theory of how an AI agent could be built to make this decision.
So let's go back to the example of the pitcher having to decide on a action in
a particular situation in the world. So the pitcher has several kinds of
knowledge. Some of its knowledge is internal. It already has it. Some of it,
it can perceive from the world around it. As an example, the pitcher can
perceive the various objects here, such as the bases, first, second, third base.
The pitcher can perceive the batter here. The pitcher can perceive the current
state of the game. The specific score in the inning, the specific batter.
The pitcher can perceive the positions of its own teammates. So, all these
things the pitcher can perceive, and these then are become exact specific kinds
of knowledge that each pitcher has. The pitcher also has internal knowledge.
The pitcher has knowledge about his goals and objectives here.